- A week before the pandemic,
just as the world was shutting down,
my next guest released
her memoir, "Untamed."
Its message, that we can do hard things,
came at the perfect time for a lot of us.
What?!
To date, it sold over 2 million copies
and spent 65 straight
weeks on the New York Times
best-seller list.
So, what?!
I read it.
I not only read it, I'm like
that nerd that, literally,
I had a necklace made
of a fricking cheetah.
I'm not kidding.
I'm so in.
I'm one of those people
that she's gonna run from
at, like, events.
Like, lectures or something.
But now she has a new project,
which I already know about.
It's a podcast called
"We Can Do Hard Things,"
and we have her on the line right now.
So, everybody, give it
up for Glennon Doyle!
(upbeat music)
(audience applauds)
(air whooshes)
I literally, I was like, she's
gonna either think it's cute
or be like stage five clinger.
I did.
I was like, you know what,
I just want a symbol.
I just wanna see it.
'Cause I was like, "A tattoo was a lot."
So I was like, "I'm just gonna makes,"
you know, that's, I dunno, it's
permanent and I have a lot.
So, I got a necklace made.
I'm not creepy, I promise.
(Kelly laughs)
- I'm loving it.
I love it so much.
- So, you, you typically
bring people together,
but you and your wife, Abby,
set off a fierce online
debate regarding dishwashers.
- Yes, she is so controlling
about the dishwasher, Kelly.
Sometimes I load it
and she will reload it
when I leave the room.
So it's more organized.
I don't know what people's
problem is about doing that.
I'm not sure.
- Well, just to let you know,
I have found her
doppelganger and that is me.
I am Abby.
(everybody laughs)
I am the one, I'm like, "Just stop."
(Kelly laughs)
Like, "I'll do it."
But we have the video
that kicked this off.
It's awesome.
(air whooshes)
- [Abby] This is a kerfuffle.
- [Glennon] What are you talking about?
- [Abby] Glennon, this is not
how you pack the dishwasher.
- [Tish] It's gonna wash the same.
- [Glennon] Exactly, Tish.
- [Abby] No, no, no, no, no.
Here's the problem.
When I redo this, it
wouldn't even need a wash.
We could wait a whole day.
- [Glennon] You know what?
You, oh, you're gonna redo this.
You are unbelievably dish controlling.
(air whooshes)
(Kelly laughs)
(audience applauds)
- "I don't know, Glennon."
(Kelly laughs)
I saw that, and I was like-
- Untamed dishwasher.
It was an untamed dishwasher.
- I, it, well, something should be tamed,
is what I'm saying, because I saw that
and I was like, "Oh, my God.
And if there's food on it, I can't."
Like, I don't think you
need to like wash it.
But, like, there's not tiny
people in the dishwasher,
like, scrubbing it for you, you know?
So you kind of do it like...
I am 100% Abby on this one.
So, you have lost me in this.
But, I wanna say, it's nice
though, to have a partner,
like, in life that will
do the dishes with you.
I'll say that.
But, Abby, Abby is a gold
medalist and World Cup champion,
and now she's coaching your daughter.
That's so cool.
- I know.
She was coaching just a
couple of weekends ago
and they were going into penalty kicks.
And I walked over to her
and I said, "Are you good?"
And she looked very cool on the outside
and she said, "I've
never been this nervous.
Not in the World Cup,
not in the Olympics."
She was terrified, but she's
an amazing coach to the girls.
- Oh, that's so, what a cool thing
to just have in your
house, like to alert us.
Wow, it's impressive!
And speaking of your daughter,
I absolutely love this story.
She wrote and sang the
theme song for your podcast.
And I wanna show a little bit of it.
(air whooshes)
♪ 'Cause we're adventurous
and heartbreak's our map ♪
♪ A final destination we lack ♪
♪ We've stopped asking directions ♪
♪ To places they've never been ♪
(air whooshes)
(audience applauds)
You better go ahead with that vibrato.
I, was this her idea?
- Completely her idea.
She wrote the lyrics on the
way to soccer practice one day.
She is going to absolutely die,
when she sees that you are
talking about her song right now
She's gonna die.
- Oh, my gosh, I was so impressed.
- Oh, thank you, thank you.
- Yeah!
So how did it all come about, is it,
I heard that Brandi was
involved, Brandi Carlisle.
- Yeah, so, Brandi is a
dear friend of our family.
Tish wrote this little song.
I sent it to Brandi and Brandi said,
"Glennon, this is a really good song."
And then she sent it back
to us, all produced up.
And she sang background for Tish.
And it's just, Tish is such
a sensitive little girl,
and it's so wonderful
to have her find music
as a way to express
herself and show her heart.
It's been, just absolutely wonderful.
- 100%, I mean, the arts are for empaths.
Like, I think that's
where you feel everything
and you express everything.
I, 100%.
So, this podcast though,
is a family affair.
So, can you tell us about it?
Everyone's kind of involved, right?
- Well, I mean, we
started it during COVID,
so, we weren't, like,
allowed to be with anyone
but the family.
(Kelly laughs)
- Those were your options.
- My options were just sitting
at my kitchen table, right?
We had to work with what we had.
But, I really, I've started
recording it with my sister
and my sister has been
my, I call her my lobster.
She's been my person since
I was four years old.
And we've spent our entire
life talking about hard things
and healing from everything together.
And so now, I get to, she's
just like the best thing I have
and now I get to give her to
the world through this podcast.
And it's just been such a joy.
- Oh, I have a sister like that as well.
My older sister is also, well,
and nobody ever thinks
she's my older sister.
She'll love that I said that.
But she's my lobster as well.
- So interesting because
I think that sometimes
we make the mistake of
thinking, "Okay, it's my job."
And especially for women,
"Okay, it's my job to make sure
that everybody on my island loves
and respects and accepts
me and my family."
And I think, actually,
it's like, "No, our job
and joy is to only allow
people on our island
who already do respect and
love and celebrate us."
(audience applauds)
(air whooshes)
- Amen, those that are deserving.
I'm back with bestselling
author and activist,
Glennon Doyle, y'all give it up for her.
(Kelly applauds)
That was a clip from her new podcast,
"We Can Do Hard Things."
The pandemic, though, it
upended life, as we know it.
And as the world gets
back to somewhat normal,
Glennon has advice for how we
can navigate this transition.
And I'll take all the advice
and make all the necklaces about it.
Well, some of our audience members
have questions for Glennon.
Malane, from Seattle, what's
your question for Glennon?
- So, you guys all have multiple kids.
We have three boys, ages, 16, 13, and 12,
and each one of them is
navigating this back to normal
so differently.
Our oldest is probably
my, our most introverted,
but he's got the baseball and
the sports and that's helping.
Our middle child is our free spirit,
has a nice group of friends.
He's smack in the middle of middle school.
So he's doing pretty well.
Our youngest has withdrawn during all this
and he's our Tish.
Like, he's the sweet sensitive
one that always has had
a lot of friends and has
been great with adults.
And so, I'm just wondering
what suggestions do you have
for how to navigate this
with them individually
and give them the support that they need?
- Okay, Malane.
Here's how I feel about these little ones.
I just don't want us to forget
that we have all been
through a huge trauma, right?
None of, we're just like all
expecting to go back to normal,
everyone should be normal.
But we've all been through so much.
And these kids have experienced stuff
that we've never experienced, right?
And our sensitive ones
have been feeling it all.
So they might have the
longest process of recovering
and going back to normal, right?
But remember what we talk
about over and over, Malane,
that being human is not about
feeling happy all the time.
It's about feeling everything, right?
So we just be, we just
be so relentlessly tender
and gentle with these little ones.
And we let them to recover
at whatever pace they are recovering.
And we don't rush them
and we don't push them back into normalcy.
We just allow them to feel it all.
And we let them see us feel it all, right?
We let them see us a
little anxious and scared.
And, when they, the more
fully human they see us being,
the more fully human they
will allow themselves to be.
- Thank you.
- But, thinking about that,
no, it is, it is funny.
I don't know if this
is a good or bad thing
and maybe you can answer,
or give, you know,
enlighten me with what you think, Glennon.
But I, my daughter feels everything.
How you describe your
daughter, is 100% River.
And she feels everything in the room.
She takes it all on everyone's emotion.
She can't, she's a walking little me.
But is it good or bad,
do you think to say,
'cause even last night, like,
we were talking about
something and I was like,
"Okay, it's okay to be
frustrated and angry.
Totally okay."
I just don't, I don't think it's good,
maybe if we sit in it all night.
Like, let's talk about it and let's do it,
but let's not sit in it.
I was like, "We can have a moment
if you need to do it every day
and you need to talk
about this because we're,"
you know, our family is
going through a divorce.
So, it's like, "We can talk about it.
Let's go, let's, I wanna go
there, but I don't wanna sit
in this like emotional day."
Is that bad or not?
Or, I don't know
- Kelly, I have the exact same,
I have this theory that
we just pendulum parents.
So, I felt like my parents
didn't give me enough space
to feel my feelings.
So then I accidentally taught my kids
that they should feel all
their feelings all the time.
And, sometimes, I'm watching
Tish talking about her feelings
for the second hour.
And I'm like, "You know
what, I did you wrong."
(Kelly laughs)
"I should have taught you
to suffer silently," right?
"'Cause this is," oh, we just overdo it.
And, Kelly, I said several times,
lots of times to these kids,
"You may continue feeling your feelings.
I just need you to do it in
your room, away from me."
Just us parents.
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh, my God.
That was amazing.
And thank you, Malane.
What a great question.
A lot of us parents are,
are struggling with that.
All our kids are experiencing,
not just the pandemic,
but you know, the previous administration
whatever side of the fence
you are, it was very intense.
And it was constantly,
something happening.
It's been a rough few years.
Like, no matter what side
of the fence you're on,
it's been hard for kids and adults.
So, like you said, there's
been a lot of trauma.
And, everybody, "We Can Do
Hard Things" with Glennon Doyle
is available wherever
you get your podcasts.
Do yourself a favor and listen.
And don't forget to pick up "Untamed."
I promise you'll love it.
And if you don't, then you're wrong.